steve is with us in New York hey Steve
how are you hey Sonia thank you for
being with us so what is your net worth
sir
it's about 2.9 million right now okay
very cool and what's the mix of that so
we've got our house fully paid off
that's worth about 750
we've got about 1.2 million in
retirement savings we've got over
600,000 for our kids in their 529 and
Yukie AIDS we're great more about that
how many kids have you got so 3 but I'm
pretty sensitive about them not having
college debt yeah I'm thinking they can
go buddy where they want to go you've
done great Wow right maybe even law
school who knows yeah that's right all
kinds of stuff about another 250 and
mutual funds and other savings gotcha
how old are you 5450 fifty four five
four yeah okay cool and how much of this
did you inherit no I'm lucky my parents
are both still around nothing you didn't
inherit any of it okay and what should
bend your income range or during your
working lifetime and maybe the average
yes crazy because it's true you know I
was definitely of those people who
started out making $25,000 years and
second ten years to get 40,000 and at
some point I was making 300,000 because
to just just keep working you just keep
at it because I went from being a
professional to a manager to an
executive working in entertainment
professional sports for a while
telecommunications so you know I say the
average is probably between 85 and maybe
95 so if we were going to give you a
career a title what would we call you I
heard a marketing ok marketing
obsessional okay a marketing guy okay
cool and your degree is in what I get
three degrees I've got a bachelor's
degree I've gotten in two masters
degrees one in telecommunications what
they used to be called television radio
and one mr.chen validation okay very
cool your GPA well I will probably say I
was in the bottom half of my high school
class David and I was a 3.9 GPA in
college so at a certain point I did have
to turn that around
at a certain point you decide to study
on staying in the library till midnight
was a good way to spend my time okay
gotcha and how much of the 2.9 is a
result of you borrowing money to build
wealth no no no it was really just kind
of grinding that my wife and I both
working hard trying it out don't you
what part does giving play in your
financial plan we're really active with
our local YMCA my wife is in Board of
Directors there our name is on the wall
of the building so that's something
we're pretty proud of the great
Community Resource here what we live
about in suburban New Jersey the great
community resource for us and so that's
something we're really proud of being
able to support that organization good
good group very cool what's the most
expensive pair of jeans you ever bought
I knew an expensive pair of jeans my
wife bought me one for Christmas
six years ago so that's probably about a
hundred bucks but yeah I wear them all
the time in their six years old it works
oh yeah I didn't know the cars a lot of
35 so the areas of my life I skimmed on
were kind of odd because I just tried to
live close to work I lived in urban
areas where I could just take the train
thirty-five-year-old buy my first car
Wow
okay well that's it for a New Yorker
okay I got you yeah so what advice do
you have for the 25 year old that's
listening can anybody still do it in
America yeah I mean really you know that
first part of your career I mean I now
I'm on the fact semi-retired I'm a
part-time college professor and I work
with young people now I would say you
know that early part of your career
really focus on yourself and investing
in yourself and you know obviously you
don't want to borrow but you know for me
like you know just focusing on my
education getting better at my job just
bad the first 10 years don't worry about
the money right away get good at what
you do the money comes later there you
go very good good word Steve good word
thank you for joining us sir you're a
hero we're talking to millionaires this
our real ones not mythological the real
ones how did they do it if you copy them
you might be one this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000
income